عادت اندريسا اوراك للظهور امام الكاميرا
لاستعراض جسمها ووجهها الذين كان سببا في
شهرتها بعدما خضعت لعمليات
تجميليه تقول اوراك انها خضعت لاكثر من
عشر عمليات منها لانفها وعظام خدها وفكها
وحقنت شفتيها عده مرات كما انها غيرت مظهر
ثدييها مرتين وخضعت لعمليه شفط الدهون
مرتين واما في الصور قبل العمليات تظهر
اندريسا وهي نحيله بعد ان وضعت طفلا في
بدايه شبابها تنافست في مسابقه صاحبه افضل
مؤخره التي يجرى تنظيمها في البرازيل عام
2012 ولكن كل هذه العمليات اوشكت على
قتلها ففي نوفمبر تشرين الثاني الماضي
عانت اندريسا من انتكاسه صحيه بعد حقن
فخذيها بماده الهيدروجيل ادت الى تهتك
بانسجة الحكومه انها لن تجدد الترخيص
لماده الهيدروجيل اما الان فان اندريس
تحذر من جانبها الناس من الغرور المفرط
تقول ان الخضوع لعمليه تجميليه لديها كان
امرا بسيطا للغايه ارادت ازاله احد
اضلاعها ليبدو خصرها اقل حجما وانحف كما
انها ارادت قطع اصابع قدميها حتى تتمكن من
ارتداء احذيه ذات مقاسات صغيره وهي ليست
الوحيده التي تخضع لهذا النوع من جراحات
التجميل ففي عام 2013 كان عدد العمليات
الجراحيه في البرازيل اكثر من اي بلد اخر
مع تزايد الاقبال على جراحه تكبير الثديين
والمؤخره واما اندريسا فهي تقول انها لن
تجري عمليه تجميليه اخرى لكنها ايضا ترفض
في الوقت نفسه ان تعود الى نفس شكلها
السابق